[Music]
when lover made the defender they got it
right the first time that's why they
haven't changed the body style what I
think they didn't realize was how iconic
and cultish the car was going to become
my name is Matthew Perman I'm the
founder of West Coast Defender we take
vintage Land Rover Defenders and update
them restore them and bring new life to
a vintage car
customers know land Rover's
reputation this car has been on the road
for 68 years now it's a solid solid made
car the only way you can get a Land
Rover Defender 110 or 90 in the United
States as it was 25 years or
[Music]
older anytime we find a good Defender we
buy whether we have a customer lined up
or
not we get the cars from all over the
world mostly Europe at the moment we've
got three Scouts and we'll get a call
there's a car in X country we'll have
somebody on a plane that day or the next
day out there looking at a car cuz
usually when a Defender comes up you got
about 24 hours to get it before go
somewhere
[Music]
else the chassis sort of like the spine
so as long as the chassis is good we can
put on a new door we can work on the
engine but as soon as the spne goes
can't deal anything with it really the
only thing we care
[Music]
about when we get a car it comes to us
pretty Bare Bones and basically we rip
the whole thing apart we start going
through the mechanics we take the doors
off we take the roof off we start
working through the engine put
everything on there brand new and try to
bring it up to the 21st
century heated seats air conditioning
power windows power locks navigation
everything you'd have a 2014
[Music]
car a lot of hard work in business does
go into all the fun that's here there's
a lot of behind the scenes r that goes
on but we get a lot of orders we
obviously do make a profit on the cars
and yeah business is
[Music]
good